my wife has a gambling problem let's get  started  Oh miss she's not very big I hope we  gonna play I bring the back yeah take  this you'll feel much better  what was that I don't know we need some  kind loves and money  we heard Irina but a price on your head  really many many things as 5.67 dives in  there spike jockeys drinks this looks a  real ring with the fake ones it has to  [Music]  the longest three days in my life that  information but if you get to wear  shorts like that you must expect to be  shocked mustn't you  the other girl in yellow  [Applause]  without that parade  she's trying to tell me something she  has a lot of resentments I mean did she  have any idea how privileged she  actually is and to be adopted by a  celebrity she said she's never heard of  you  that little [ __ ]  you